today's topic we are going to be
reacting to other Jubilee videos last
time to people like you guys are being
unfair okay you guys just picked the
worst one out of that whole channel so
we're gonna pick the other two episodes
of Jubilees uploaded do you wanna start
with the man or the woman
[Music]
are you guys men's rights channel are
you guys Loki finding the most
detestable ladies to do this bro it
makes me speak up alright let's go
nothing to stop me I'm all the way out I
mean I'm hoping not to continue this
pattern of very very bad men
[Applause]
[Music]
how many guys do you think end up with
me three anything I wanna see what yeah
sounds like what she's I think last time
I picked zero for the last girl she got
one so I'm gonna pick one this time
even though I think she deserves zero I
[Music]
love to dance so I don't like it when
I'm with somebody who's a total debbie
downer or boring and just kind of stands
there and doesn't want to dance every
time a guy leaves like her father left
what she takes a really terribly every
time a guy it's a guy Jesus I would
definitely want someone open-minded but
not freak so you shouldn't be in two
feet but you know a little choking for
fun
can we just say there's nothing freaky
about choking like that's pretty much
the baseline for 90% of women I'm not
talking about it's like I'm just talking
about like gently placing some pressure
on both sides of the neck in order to
not suffocate her but hit that pressure
okay okay feels like sometimes I'm like
hitting it and I'm like I was looking at
the girl and I'm like choke me you know
so I she chokes me I'm like yeah anyways
but normally if I say talk me go this
way
I do like him tall because I'm pretty
tall for an asian girl and when I put on
my heels
I would like to still be shorter than
mom I am so they need to be I think at
least 511 but I prefer like six feet
tall that's absolutely stupid
that you put on shoes and you determine
I can't be with someone it's gotta be
one of the dumbest and half of the night
you're gonna be like oh my feet hurt
carry me I would not want to be with
somebody who wants kids within seven
years I love kids I've been in on since
I was ten so I'm like unnatural around
babies and kids but I want to really
just share a love with somebody that's
so great and it's all about loving each
other before we can you know bring
somebody else in the world I think you
should be mentally stable as well
financially stable because you're gonna
be responsible for shaping their future
it says things better than the other one
oh yeah yeah the other girls are out too
potato light potatoes oh yeah it's
pretty good you know what I have a
younger brother and anybody younger than
me I just automatically think of my
brother so take it back I take it all
back
yeah take it all back I said that oh
yeah take it back yeah if you think
about someone younger than you and you
automatically think about your brother
there's nothing wrong with the dude it's
you if you think about someone older
than you and you immediately think of
your father it's you it's not him it's
you just want to put that out there
where the problem is it's not the guy
that's younger than you it's really you
wrong with you I don't get that let's go
like they could be the hottest person in
the room and if they tell me they're
even a month younger than me I'm just
like oh I just see my brother and it's
like oh look you got issues I think you
just want to your brother and it's
something you have a hard time accepting
we've had he's really really hot Wow oh
brother would not date my brother yeah
well you discarded people for those
visas is so you deserved it I like how
she said I'm gonna die alone and then
the guy said something less worse which
is you're gonna be single for a while
and she was hurt yeah that'd be like me
saying hey I'm the most ugly person and
the priest comes in and he says yeah see
this is why that's rude I take it back
yeah you take it back okay but it's
still my phone [ __ ] so don't even play
that can you put your finger down don't
get sugary with me how many guys would
you think would be left I thought there
would be maybe four guys left but there
were none so today I learned that uh
my criteria is not I guess easy as I
thought it was but I'm okay with that I
was hoping she was gonna realize that
maybe she's being a little unreasonable
and it's contributing to her dating woes
you know like you know what they call
insanity right it's doing the same thing
over and over doing expecting a
different result she came into this
saying oh I make terrible choices in men
I mean I'm hoping not to continue this
pattern of very very bad men
she made bad criterias which eliminated
all the potential man and she said I'm
okay with the way I choose to date I
used to really beat myself up in my past
relationships after they ended because I
felt like I wasn't good enough but I
think I'm at a place in my life right
now where I know what I want and there's
nothing wrong with having these
standards
you shouldn't have to bend your values
and what you want to please somebody
else this is what kills me people who
say I know what I want if you know what
you want how come you've always chose
terrible talk about values but then
again the height of a guy is not a value
that's not a value that's a preference
out of the five things you said there
was one value which was a family but the
rest party is not a value you know it's
like just people who say they're not
superficial then they do one of these
shows and then they picked the hottest
person every single time I'm like just
say you're in for superficial reasons
and it's okay it's okay
but don't be sure I'm thinking people
beaten you're not it's not bad this that
was not valued but man motto I'll say -
I guess I was thrown up around you see
how he's already aiming low that's
immense taken a few else but yeah
I'm not that great if it's your hook
then hey that's my life already so it's
cool
you took hands to the face all on the
regular basis like hey if I get to I get
to if I get one okay if it's zero hey
nothing change right we didn't make
these videos were just reacting but in
your opinion who of these two do you
think is gonna have the most success be
objective these are not based on gender
but based off how they act cuz we're
watching this for the first time yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
they got a lot of Asians in these series
this is quite impressive how many Asian
people they may have either on the west
coast yeah make sense where the Mexicans
at though part Mexican spicy Asians
alright this is one of those attractive
[ __ ] that really act like he don't get
no poom poom but he probably does and he
stumbles into it like he's like shaggy
who solves the mystery and pretends he
doesn't know how but he actually looks
like the blond guy out of the scooby-doo
pen that's what he knows self-awareness
you know why he knows cuz he knows what
is his assets are and are not he's gonna
have to go out there so he knows what he
can put in value you know I mean like he
looks like a guy that he looks young he
lives he looks adorable only on Thor he
saw him I paint like I'm a play like
that oh yeah this is the kind of guy
that girls like to husband up easy yeah
he's like the unassuming hot yeah which
is fine he just knows what the hell he's
doing here yeah I can't no poom poom
meanwhile stabbing nice is that
no if you go for house it's better like
a cocky guy's gonna get somebody beat he
knows he doesn't have the he doesn't
have the physique of hey what's up who
wants some I think I definitely prefer
girls who have been in a relationship
before or at least maybe a long-term
relationship because they really kind of
know what it's like to be in
relationship and starting something new
with somebody who's never had that you
see a difference between homegirl who
did astrology and him was like I'd like
to be with somebody who's been in past
relationships for do you not see a
difference in those two things but you
know Scorpios right why waste your time
with this like well maybe like he'll
change or it'll work because if he's a
Scorpio and you don't want to Scorpio
it's like why waste your time get a
Libra like oh my god yeah even the way
they phrase their four sentences them in
those days like if you've never been in
a relationship please leave the circle
boy other ones like if you're religious
don't be
yeah entitled because she's the one I
was stone with on the receiving end yeah
what he always asked to get you have to
get yes oh yeah yeah oh [ __ ] there's a
lot of people man have never been
released
I think what's surprising about this is
how many people under the age of 23
have never been in a relationship yeah
apparently it's super common nowadays to
have never dated people are like you in
college and stuff like that it's
dependent of the background of the
people yeah dependent of their
backgrounds they yeah I mean they never
date yeah people think that the young
younger people have more nowadays but
that's not what the statistics say no
they don't they don't they have less
than before yeah I mean no cuz they're
more informed and stuff like that and
it's more terrible to talk about it more
and
open and they have Netflix there Netflix
there's less pressure so because I
remember being like kid we're just born
I'm like I guess I want okay we'll go
for the clickbait first you know getting
experimental in the bedroom is always
fun for me that sounds like I'm
Christian Grey but nothing too crazy I
don't like like things getting boring
that's where you dump it I know you got
poom poom cuz before you said zero and
now you are yeah I like the experience
stuff and stuff like that brother told
this little okie know what the hell you
this guy's the unassuming you try to
come in budget this is good
[Music]
see it's not like boom fan in whatever
happy happening it's like okay how can i
phrase this still these people around
him are there for him
but he still watches like okay how can i
phrase this so this doesn't sound off
bad yeah got that out of the way you
know I guess this guy gets mad poom poom
yeah you know this is called the
unassuming boy the boy you never see
coming
he doesn't have his hair in a position
he pretends like he doesn't get laid at
all he says all the right things but all
of a sudden you show up in the bedroom
and man's got lube tampons
after morning pills everything already
set up for you this dude is that guy I
don't like you when girls believe in
horoscopes
yo this guy's clearly not a Scorpio I'm
gonna make a whole video about this one
day but my distaste for women who are
obsessed with with horoscopes is so
elevated
whatever venus isn't gatorade so let's
keep on she's like the weirdest thing
ever
but I hate it when someone's like oh I'm
a Libra
I don't think click the moons aren't
aligned for this this month so we can't
really you know get over because we
wouldn't click
[Music]
goddamnit
huh okay I like girls who are into the
Arts in my creative arts so people who
are already down that path when we
started dating while studying arts or
you know anything within that field
career-wise that's something to talk
about you know funny responses that's
fine happy face my hand pull my pants up
about the lobby's yes look at that look
from yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah don't
she's going in I was surprised at how
many people had not been in a long-term
relationship maybe I was too specific on
my my dates Wow do you see the
difference my dues this guy got five
girls and he still thought to myself
maybe that criteria specific where the
other one was like I'm sticking to my
guns and that's what it is cuz I don't
know what I want now single but I'm okay
it's hard I'm not picky John you know
I'm a lover of all beings
oh wow that was boy yeah Wow told you is
gonna come out I just want to say one
thing I can't wait for you to fall for
me for us to sleep together and I'm
never gonna call you back I'm a lover of
ghosting because ghosts are being too
all right so listen
people are something to look at this is
man bashing or whatever woman backing
that's really not the case they made
these videos you saw the difference and
like even if the woman had the man's
approach I would feel the same way
I think people in general have to learn
that sometimes what you look for in a
partner is too restricted and you are
not allowing yourself to find out what
you actually like in someone by
discovering it we discover we like
things by actually trying them like
cuisine I didn't have sushi until 2
years ago really I'm 29
I had sushi I'm like that's fire I'm
gonna try ramen next week who knows I
need to try to know so all this to say
to you guys you saw the difference in
their approach and for the guy he even
though he got five women who were
interested you know he's understanding
that look some of them are not gonna
work out some of them were not going to
be compatible sexually whatever so what
can I do to allow myself to have the
most opportunities to potentially find a
good meat whereas the woman is
delusional she is absolutely the most
asinine restrictions and not only that
when she ends up with bad results she
blames it on the people around her and
not her own restrict so that she's not
the one who's gonna go fish yeah they're
usually in the receiving end so they
don't have to change the way they see
things I mean at the end of the day
that's inspiring in the relationship
because some things are not gonna click
and you're gonna be less inclined to
change those things because you don't
have to yeah but yeah man have to change
all this we have to be versatile a
little bit more versatile because we
gotta go fish because we take the hell's
I think that's that's the that's the
correlation between both and that's the
reason why I'm booboo as your looks are
gonna fade oh it's gonna be harder for
you you're young now it's going to get
harder as you get older a lot of people
like these are my standards it doesn't
matter okay have your standards I don't
mind because restrictive is you want but
don't complain and expect sympathy if
you own in a McDonald's and you asked
you for
people with master level degrees and
nobody's applying don't get mad when
you're McDonald's not operational nobody
wants your happy meal just take it back
with some of your standards it's not
necessary and I'm telling you guys you
guys are gonna find out about stuff you
didn't even know you liked by trying new
things so be more open-minded that's all
anything else you want I like I like
making people uncomfortable
yep I know that you know that I actually
enter situations like yeah yeah really
knowing that you're gonna make people
uncomfortable yeah you know what it is
though
because like you know there's like a lot
of niceties in life like it there's a
lot of like formal stuff that we do that
we feel like we have to but when you
throw people off with discomfort you
start to like really see what they're
like does that make sense
like like sometimes I'll go for a
handshake and I'll hold on to it for too
long yeah and then automatically they
have to break whatever character they
think we have to present to the world
and I'm getting a glimpse of who that
person is yeah so it's just funny to see
people react like oftentimes people like
a view being [ __ ] disturber but for me
it's like it's it gets to be slightly
more authentic because you can't just
keep up this facade of like this is a
business meeting you know what I mean
obviously laughter breaks things down
and then we start to get more
comfortable with one another and then
you start to be like okay I'm getting to
see a real person rather than like oh
how are you you know what I mean so
that's what I can't do the same thing
but not the same morning how do you do I
call [ __ ] out okay if you [ __ ] up some
[ __ ] I've called it out if some [ __ ] is
awkward I'm gonna call it out if if
you're being dumb I'm gonna call it out
if you like I call out things Toretto
so but that because cuz like you said
most people are trying to be nice and
trying to not like Oh something they're
open what happened there yeah what's
that what is this and in the pickup
artist world we call that nagging right
you know what I mean right when you if
there's a set a set of people there's
two girls the most good-looking girl is
gonna be used to have all the attention
so anytime she
to have a little bit of attitude you
never write but I do that to you what
Meg okay just why you said it
you don't make okay okay III I feel yeah
I see the difference no just confused
reside don't make I'm new to this world
of monetization button and it's flashing
right now you guys are teetering on the
line I'm sorry I'm making money and
being broke okay so let's keep it going
to basically make her okay yeah yeah but
I do that to everybody just yeah see
y'all that's good I like that it's a
quality and be any react you just you
see how they're gonna be yeah you know
most people call me a jackass for that
mm-hmm but I don't really care like oh
you're a real person you're not the same
like I don't care we're not friends I
can't do the the surface level like how
are ya yeah how's the I can't do that I
can't do it so me like I'll be like
what's up and I'll just stay quiet after
that if I know that's who you are and
that's always your vibe whenever I'm
like we don't have to talk more cuz I
can't like take my energy to put in this
useless conversation do it that's why
people think I'm a terrible person
you know what I'm saying yeah for the
most part because like if you see me at
comedy clubs I just stay my corner I'm
tight that's every day I stay my corner
and I'm quiet yeah because for most
people I can't have real conversations
because that's not where they're at and
that's okay I'm not going to force them
on but y'all fake y'all that's wack to
be you know I'm saying so I'm just like
better to be quiet let people enjoy
themselves and however they like to talk
and I'm just not gonna engage in that
but if I see what see more I see
somebody that I can real drive with then
we open up and it's always fun times and
fun conversations I don't have to
pretend
yeah to do all the [ __ ] that I don't
care I give everybody 50 points hmm if I
meet you you have 50 points I don't know
you so that's 50 points whatever you do
that's you but you can lose or win
points right people that are in the - so
the first time I think I'm gonna be like
hey what's up how you doing this is Matt
and the more I see you act
like this is a piece of [ __ ] and I'm a
stop I'm just not gonna acknowledge you
my head was a and what's like what's up
what's something that would deduct like
20 points [ __ ] just shitty attitude in
general just thing you know I know
you're not real you know you know I know
please sleazebag thing right I know you
a sleazebag you know it's a minus 100
for me when someone really wants your
attention and affection you know I mean
that's immediately oh god yeah yeah like
when you ever had conversation with
people and you know they're trying to
steal your energy I mean like like like
like you see these people and you
physically want to defend yourself we've
talked about a few people in this how
many seem like there's certain women
like if I see them I will move away so I
don't have to talk to them because I
know that they just want to take from me
and those people like your debt to me I
don't want you around I had a party one
time and I was inviting this girl said
yeah I'm coming with this girl and I'm
like don't bother coming stay I like you
but I dislike her so much I don't want
you here because she's gonna kill my
vibe you've had a thousand points she
has - mm yeah that's a perfect way to
put it so there are certain things that
immediately kill off a person for me but